a very warm welcome to all of you six
months after the outbreak of the
pandemic the corona virus is still
spreading around the globe it is
threatening people's lives and
livelihoods and we all know that we can
only defeat it when the world has a
vaccine this must be our main focus we
have to develop a vaccine and distribute
it to every corner of the world as
quickly as possible and we need better
treatments that are affordable for
everyone and reliable tests we need all
this especially in those regions of the
world that cannot rely on strong health
care systems to make all this happen we
need three things first to move fast
second to act together no country will
be safe if the others are not and
finally we need money in the order of
tens of billions of dollars but
investing billions today will save us
trillions in the future the world needs
to unite so that the virus can be
defeated once and for all the good news
is this is already happening one month
ago a worldwide coalition came together
to shape the coronavirus global response
to the pandemic we all rallied around
the World Health Organization when it
called for global mobilization and on
the 4th of May the European Commission
launched an international donors
conference with a large number of
countries as co-hosts more than 40
countries came together and this gives
us hope more and more countries realize
that we are all together in this and
that no one is safe until we are all
safe
but that was only the beginning of our
marathon the next milestone is just
around the corner on June 4th we need to
ensure that Gavi the vaccine Alliance
has the funding it needs to continue
doing its work in the poorest countries
and today with this event we are moving
to the next phase of our mobilization we
need further commitment from all
partners and we need more resources we
need to fast-track research and
development of a vaccine this normally
takes up to 10 years but we don't have
that time and we need a vaccine for all
who need it not just for those people in
countries that can afford it
and this is why I am very grateful for
the engagement of so many influences
activists private corporations
philanthropists and civil society
organizations you have contributed to
putting a spotlight on this campaign and
just like you thousands of people have
shown that they care with a small
donation or sometimes just a social
media post but it makes a difference and
it is for all these people that today we
are launching a new campaign called
global goal is unite for our future the
idea for this campaign comes from global
citizen and I'm so honored to give my
patronage to the initiative during the
next month until June 27th more people
will make their voices heard calling on
everyone to contribute to our common
fight against coronavirus and then on
June 27th I will host the final pledging
summit where businesses foundations and
citizens will have the opportunity to
join forces with public donors
fifteen governments have already
confirmed their support in the second
part of our pledging marathon so let me
thank Austria Canada Belgium France
Germany Italy Mexico Morocco New Zealand
Norway Saudi Arabia the United Arab
Emirates South Africa Spain and the
United Kingdom you will find videos and
quotes from our supporters on the
website of the European Commission and
we count on many more to join in the
next four weeks the money that we will
raise will finance testing programs
treatments and vaccines for countries
everywhere in the world and for everyone
who needs them this is the only way to
overcome this pandemic and to avoid
another on June 27th with unite for our
future everyone can contribute to
life-saving medical innovation to make
coronavirus history and to make history
in uniting the world let me leave the
floor now to Hugh Evans the CEO of
global citizen you will tell you more
about unite for our future the global
citizen community has made the headlines
all across the world just a few weeks
ago the event you organised with many
many artists one world together at home
has raised 127 million dollars in
donations Hugh you are showing that
everyone of us can help change the world
do you have the floor Thank You
President on the line and thank you to
the European Commission for your
leadership in the continued fight
against covert 19 as president von der
Leyen said much much more still needs to
be done to ensure we can find a
long-term
solution to this pandemic and do all
that we can to rebuild and strengthen
global health systems to avoid future
ones on March 16 global citizen received
a phone call from United Nations deputy
secretary-general Amina Muhammad asking
global citizen to mobilize our artists
ambassadors to share important Cova 19
messages in a matter of days our artists
partners Coldplay and John Legend helped
us kickstart a virtual concert series
that was passed to hundreds of artists
all over the world a week later we
partnered with Lady Gaga Sir Paul
McCartney Andre Bocelli Stevie Wonder
Elton John Taylor Swift and the Rolling
Stones to launch one world together at
home culminating with the April 18th
global broadcast which has broken the
record so the most funds raised in a
remote concert through the advocacy
efforts of that campaign we successfully
drove over 127 million dollars to
support the w-h-o and regional kovat
relief efforts positive strides of
containment and tracking are being made
and the most brilliant minds on the
planet are working together to find
therapeutics and a vaccine but the
covert 19 pandemic as we know is far
from being over we must take charge of
our shared future for the good of our
planet and for our fellow global
citizens indeed restarting our economy
can only truly happen once we've made
tests treatments and vaccines available
to everyone and everywhere for those who
need them so today it is our great
pleasure to announce global goal unite
for our future the next step to continue
to raise the billions needed to achieve
this outcome under the patronage of
president von der Leyen the global goal
unite for our future campaign and
pledging summit will focus on making
testing treatments and vaccines
available to
everyone everywhere who needs them and
help put the world back on track to
achieve the sustainable development
goals scientists doctors and researchers
from all over the world and working
around the clock together to find
solutions and through this campaign we
want to tell their stories by focusing
on the innovative spirit that this
moment of historic crisis has triggered
from today through to June 27 we'll be
calling on every single one of our world
leaders to step up in support of funding
research and critically equitable
distribution of testing treatments and a
vaccine and we are not only supporting
wonderful organizations like the Global
Fund find SETI and the w-h-o who are
working on covert 19 but also the garvey
replenishment on June 4th to ensure we
support routine immunizations against
other important diseases we're also
inviting the private sector to join us
on June 27th and make contributions
towards limiting the pandemics impact on
the most marginalized communities we
must use this moment of unity to move
forward as a global community we'll be
encouraging the millions of global
citizens engage in our movement every
month to support this campaign and we're
privileged to be partnering with the
European Commission Bloomberg
philanthropies the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation and the Wellcome Trust
on this initiative the power of the
artist community to drive change and
unite people to stand together is step
into nunn the campaign which will lead
into the pledging summit will again
feature support from some of the biggest
artists and entertainers in the world
including incredible artists like
Coldplay Chris Rock Hugh Jackman Idris
Elba and Sabrina album J Balvin
Justin Bieber Lady Gaga Miley Cyrus
Shakira Adam Lambert Chloe and Halle
Dionne Warwick Femi Kuti Lang Lang fair
and Milan Padma Lakshmi and Rachel
Brosnahan and it is now my great
pleasure to introduce two of the leading
forces of global goal unite for our
future Hugh Jackman and Miley Cyrus
[Music]
thank you and thank you to the European
Commission for hosting us today as you
both touched on people around the world
desperate to return to work school and
see their loved ones now the only way
we'll be able to do this the only way we
will be able to open up our economies
back up is by ensuring kovin 19
treatments are available to all now we
need a movement of global citizens
calling on governments corporations and
philanthropists to make the investments
needed to end the covert 19 era there
are lands full of the best scientists
all over the world racing to develop
over 19 tools and treatments at great
speed but we have a long way to go and
that's why I'm joining global citizen
and the European Commission today to
encourage everyone to take action in
support of the global goal unite for our
future campaign it's an honor to be here
asking everyone watching to take action
and support the global goal unite for
our future campaign at a time where
we've seen in justices in our society
increase even more we now have the
opportunity to take a stand for equality
and health for all because this pandemic
has affected our entire world we need to
ensure that everyone everywhere has the
solutions for this pandemic testing
treatments and a vaccine together people
around the globe across ages borders and
identities are calling on governments
businesses and
antipas to step up their funding for
these critical solutions so join us by
going to global citizen or foreign /
global goal unite and take action today
thank you very much
Hugh Jackman and Miley Cyrus I cannot
thank enough all those artists who have
used their voice and their charisma to
raise awareness on how everyone can do
their part sure I know we also have
messages from some people who are
investing their own private resources
for the common good over to you thank
you madam president
indeed we won't be able to beat Kovan 19
without the private sector and leading
philanthropist fully engaged in this
process and we're grateful for our
partners who will be joining this global
effort this campaign would not be
possible without the support of these
incredible leaders take a look the
coronavirus is an enormous global
challenge and meeting it requires global
cooperation Bloomberg philanthropies is
working with the World Health
Organization and public health leaders
around the world to help countries slow
the spread of the virus and save lives
we're also glad to be teaming up with
global citizen and the European
Commission on this new campaign called
global gold
for our future together with all our
partners will seek to accelerate the
development of vaccines and treatments
will work to ensure a testing and
treatment are available to more people
were alive and will help countries
rebuild their economies and support
those in need
for all this together and the more we
collaborate during this pandemic you
haven't been hearing much good news but
there is good news about the progress in
science around the world researchers are
making huge strides in drug and vaccine
development we have a good chance of
having a working vaccine by January and
that would make it the fastest vaccine
ever created in human history but we
also have to ask what good is this
vaccine if we can't get it to all the
people in the world the virus doesn't
respect borders and it doesn't care
about what nationality you are so for
the world to overcome kovin 19 we need
more than just the breakthrough science
we also need breakthroughs in generosity
and global cooperation on this score I'm
very grateful for the leadership of
Ursula von der Leyen and the European
Commission last year it was hard to
imagine that the world could come
together to solve this kind of big
global challenge if there was a
narrative about how the world was
changing it was mostly about turning
inward we only have just a fraction of
the resources we need so far but I
believe this pandemic is starting to
pull the world in the direction of
working together
it's reminded us that we're connected
not just by common humanity but by our
vulnerability to a virus that links all
of our health to each other and so we
have to look out for each other
amid the sadness of the pandemic
this is a bright spot and it should keep
us all hopeful rolling out tests
treatments and vaccines globally is the
only exit strategy from this crisis
developing manufacturing and
distributing those tools to everybody
who needs them will require all
countries to work together
it's what health workers need what the
public expect and what we all deserve I
would like to thank President Ursula von
der Leyen for your leadership and
support every national leader in
stepping up to collaborate in this
crisis that's why the Wellcome Trust is
backing the global citizens campaign
global goal unite our future
thank you so much to all of you for your
support of this vital campaign we'll be
making more very exciting announcements
over the coming coming weeks leading
into the pledging summit and thank you
to you president Mundelein thank you so
much and in the next four weeks we will
need all of your support to mobilize as
much funding as possible every euro
every dollar can change the life of a
woman a man or child who need a vaccine
a test or an effective treatment so
thanks to all of you who have chosen to
contribute and I promise that the
European Commission will continue to do
everything we can so that we can put an
end to this pandemic thank you and see
you on June 27th
[Music]
you